wir stellen euch heute einen
interessanten deutschen ausdruck vor
wir reden heute über den ausdruck egal
und wie ihr ihn richtig benutzt los
geht's das wort egal benutzt man im
deutschen immer dann wenn man sagen
möchte ist da sind mörder
man kann im deutschen sagen das ist egal
und das kann man übersetzen mit 1000
meter wenn man diesen spot mit einer
person benutzt dann muss man jedoch ein
dativ pronomen benutzen und das ist
wichtig zu wissen
wir haben schon mal über dativ pronomen
gesprochen hier verlinkt ich euch mal
ein video und dort haben wir zum
beispiel über diesen häufigen fehler
gesprochen dass man sagt ich bin kalt
korrekt wäre jedoch mir ist kalt also
immer wenn man im deutschen über gefühle
redet benutzt man oft dieses gastronomen
und dann klingt der satz das ist mir
egal
etwas mehr atome oder don't care also
wichtig ist dass ihr euch merkt dass ihr
dieses egal immer mit einem dativ
pronomen benutzt man sagt das ist mir
egal dass es dir egal das ist ihm oder
ihr egal das ist uns egal das ist euch
egal und das ist ihnen egal
jannis was willst du heute essen keine
ahnung aber grundsätzlich ist mir egal
egal ich könnte dir zum beispiel eine
leckere gemüsesuppe kochen oder wir
könnten bezahl bestellen
mir ist wirklich egal oder ich könnte
auch reis kochen mit einem leckeren tofu
mix ist echt egal entscheide du ja nicht
dann mache ich eine suppe und stadt dir
gibt es heute wasser was das ist mir
nicht egal wir bitte jetzt gucken wir
uns mal die verschiedenen varianten des
ausdrucks das ist mir egal an
das besondere ist nämlich dass es kurz
vorm gibt und auch längere formen die
kurzformen sind zum beispiel so was die
mir egal
man kann auch sagen ist egal oder man
kann einfach sagen egal wenn dich also
jemand fragt was möchtest du heute essen
dann kannst du einfach antworten
egal oder mir egal es gibt auch einige
bekannte teams und einige bekannte
videos und songs mit diesem wort egal
und unter anderem möchte ich euch mal
unten ein video der bvg der berliner
verkehrsbetriebe verlinken das vor
einigen jahren sehr bekannt geworden ist
dort gibt es einen schaffner der die
tickets kontrolliert und er singt immer
wieder ist mir egal ist mir egal
und zwar gibt es dort verschiedene
sachen die man in der u-bahn machen kann
oder nicht machen kann dem schaffner ist
alles egal
außer 1 man sollte immer ein ticket
dabei haben wenn ihr zu diesem thema
noch etwas mehr üben möchte vor allem
diese dativ pronomen möchtest dann
schaut euch doch mal unsere interaktiven
übungen an jede woche machen easy und
sophie interaktive übungen zu all
unseren videos und diese woche gibt es
spezielle übungen zum thema da trifft
polen und den verschiedenen ausdrücken
rund um das wort egal
um die übung zu bekommen werdet einfach
ein mitglied von easy german das geht
hier oben weil katrin
[Musik]
so kann es aber nicht aus dem haus gehen
warum das denn was sollen denn die
nachbarn denken ja das ist mir doch egal
[Musik]
in der letzten szene die ihr gesehen
habt hat die amish gesagt das ist mir
doch egal
tatsächlich gibt es von das ist mir egal
nicht nur kürzere varianten sondern auch
längere varianten und wenn man diesen
ausdruck noch mal verstärken möchte dann
kann man auch wörter hinzu nehmen dann
kann man zum beispiel sagen das ist
total egal
das ist völlig egal oder das ist doch
und gerade dieses doch hört man oft in
kombination mit diesem satz das ist doch
egal und das doch ist ein sogenannter
modal partikeln über modal partikeln
haben wir auch schon mal ein video
gemacht und speziell über das wort doch
das verlinke ich euch mal hier unten und
dort könnt ihr sehen dass man dieses
doch häufig dann benutzt wenn man etwas
verstärken möchte das ist eigentlich
nicht übersetzbar aber wenn man sagt das
ist doch egal dann heißt das eigentlich
das ist mir wirklich egal was ist doch
völlig egal
janisch soll ich kartoffeln oder nudeln
dazu kochen ja das ist mir wurscht
das ist ihm wurst zuletzt reden wir noch
über synonyme des wortes egal
in der letzten szene habt ihr gesehen
dass janisch gesagt hat das ist mir
wurst das wort wurst ist tatsächlich in
diesem fall ein synonym von egal
und das kommt daher dass man in die
wurst quasi alles rein tut also fleisch
oder stücke von dem tier dass der
metzger nicht verarbeiten kann
sie kommen in die wurst und das ist
quasi egal was da drin ist ein bisschen
eklig dieser ausdruck finde ich aber die
deutschen benutzen ihn tatsächlich sehr
oft man sagt das ist mir wurst oder das
ist mir
wurscht man kann auch sagen das ist
schnurz das ist mir schnuppe
das ist jacke wie hose oder das ist
gehüpft wie gesprungen dann hüpfen und
springen ist quasi das gleiche und egal
was man benutzt
es kommt das gleiche raus das ist
gehüpft wie gesprungen ist egal
jetzt wollen wir mal von euch wissen wie
sagt man denn auf ihrer muttersprache
egal oder das ist mir egal
und habt ihr auch so lustige synonyme
wie wir im deutschen haben schreibt uns
mal einen kommentar hier unten darüber
freuen uns sehr und wenn ihr lust habt
weiter zu üben die dativ pronomen zu
üben und auch die ausdrücke der heutigen
episode dann werdet gerne ein mitglied
von the german für fünf euro im monat
werdet ihr mitglied und unterstützt
damit auch unsere arbeit das geht
hierbei patchen und wir sehen uns ganz
bald wieder nämlich am sonntag klar
[Musik]